Eric state I've been here for the last
year and a half doing research on each
other self-driving cars and their media
representations and my thesis is titled
driverless dreams narratives ideology
into the shape of the automated car and
I'm going to be presenting sort of a
slice of that for you today trying to
encapsulate with my main argument so if
don't like a lot of people when I say
that I'm working on self-driving cars
you might think of one of a number of
things one of them weird this which is
Google's self-driving city car concept
this picture sort of started to
circulate towards the end of last year
and its continued to get a lot of lot of
sort of presents this picture it's
everywhere um the sort of device in
question is an attempt by able to move
away from their surf Prius highway
driving work towards low speed city high
complexity environments another thing
you might think about would be this
minority report which has actually been
lauded by some people in the industry as
being a relatively good representation
of what a automated vehicle system could
look like because it was done by an
actual designer but you probably didn't
think about this image and if you did
then you probably don't really have to
listen to the rest of the episode but so
here you have like a server technician
in a datacenter doing diagnostic and
repair on part of a server rack and he
also probably didn't think about this
group of people in a room monitoring and
supervising a large-scale complex system
in this case power grid and my
contention is that these last two images
are just as useful and in fact in some
ways more useful in turn
thinking about what automated vehicles
will be than the first two so basically
in this talk we're going to talk about
three main things first what are
people's ideas about automation second
we're going to talk about supervision
and high recommendation systems and
third we'll talk about how to add a high
level how the design effective vehicle
automation systems I want to say to
start and this is sort of a tues like
bring out what my main argument is here
that automation involves people it
involves people building repairing
monitoring and operating systems and
then it's really much more productive if
we think about hybrid human machine
systems rather than just thinking about
automation was just thinking about that
time so what do people think automation
is in general people seem to think
Automation the vehicles faces about
feats of robot cars this is a vision
that comes directly from science fiction
it comes from minority report which was
already it's also a vision that comes
out of our sort of cultural ideas about
what automation in factory if you look
like and what effect that's not on
society but more than that it's also a
picture that comes out google and what
sort of google has to say on how they
present themselves in terms of what
they're doing this problem i don't think
that that sort of science fiction
emphasis theories is their enemy they
really feel like this is something that
makes you know it makes it look like
we're doing cutting-edge things that
maybe no one else can do in solving big
issues so it's not a notion that they
seem to be ready to you know disabuse
people up it's also something that comes
out of research in artificial
intelligence the sort of discourse
around AI history and this is done when
that and they had research are talking
in 1997 this is actually a quote that we
hammock or textbook about AI researchers
but before we let robotic shrimpers
drive around our streets I want the
automated driver to have a general
common sense about the value of a cat
versus a child versus a car bumper about
children chasing balls with the streets
and so on about death being a very
undesirable thing and there are a couple
interesting points that come out of this
coat one is that there's the sort of
vision gear of maybe a humanoid robot
behind the wheel of a regular car
another is that we can see these moral
and ethical dilemmas coming out to the
fore here but also it's an idea that
presupposes that these things will just
be out there in the world driving around
doing stuff entirely separate from human
commands and people tend to think about
that feeds of robot cars vision as
opposed to advanced driver assistance
systems being developed by bulova
Mercedes and many others get these on
you know high-end luxury vehicles right
now they'll be available for you soon
incidents or trickling down to other
models of cars these are things like
adaptive cruise control pedestrian
detection lane-keeping incremental
improvements from the sort of system
that we have now and the opposition of
these two regimes of automation is
something that actually gets supported
by levels of automation formulations by
groups like the national highway traffic
safety administration which released
their tax on last year in order to guide
organization to those sort of lawmakers
and technical technology organizations
in terms of how they're going to develop
and regulate the systems and there are a
lot of problems with that document that
I can talk about the Q&A if people are
interested but basically what they do is
they have five levels of autonomy from
or five level emission from zero to 50
is no automation which troublingly there
are certain things in there that are
actually automated pi is like a full
automation everywhere and then they're
placed that there's place to opposite
sides of what is sort of ostensibly a
continuum but it's built into these sort
of
components and they're sort of very much
opposed one is sort of the past and one
is you know this sort of ultimate goal
that we want to get to we want to be at
level four we don't want to be it
through two one or zero but the reality
is actually different there really is a
lot of stuff in the middle there there
are a lot of sort of hybrid models to
look at and we should really take that
seriously take seriously the idea of
automation as a continuum now on this
topic Google's Chris Armisen says that
advanced driver assistance systems that
we've been talking about whom never
become fully autonomous me is a great
coat about this that's like me saying if
I work really hard at jumping one day
I'll be able to fly and I don't want to
push back too hard on that because it is
a good point that if we work at
automating one little piece at a time
it's going to take a while before all of
the pieces are complete and that's even
assuming all of those separately design
components end up working together but
that vision still assumes that the only
reasonable goal is full autonomy so
earnest ins feature is way off here on
the right hand side the sort of absolute
maximum that you can get and somewhere
in the past we were fully manual and
advanced driver assistance will only get
us part of the way but there's actually
no reason to think that that one sort of
extreme model is the way that these
things will be or should be we may just
as likely see something else in middle
in fact that may be the most productive
model for achieving certain types of
goals and so we should really consider
you know where our future might lie in
the space and that means talking about
hybridity and that means talking about
hybrid human machine systems and I have
two cases for why we need
about this the first one I'm going
through is the pragmatic case the second
is the fundamental case in the pragmatic
case is basically that self-driving cars
are hard there are a number of difficult
AI problems that need to be solved in
order to you know create automated
vehicles some of those are problems in
computer vision that you know object
detection is something that's quite
difficult there are a lot of strides
being made in that right now with new
computational approaches but it's still
something where humans are better able
to do tasks like tell a two-by-four from
a piece of foam of approximately the
same size which and those sorts of
knowledge is about what objects are made
up and what their properties are
potentially very important we move into
doing things in the real world another
difficult problem is pedestrian
interaction when we're driving through
cities we have complicated transactions
of space with bicep lists with
pedestrians there's been some work done
actually here in Media Lab in terms of
how to design a you know robotic car
that has sort of eyes that track
pedestrians you can sort of interact in
those ways but it's still a difficult
problem that people are actually
surprisingly good at that because we're
social week okay we certainly know how
to do those sorts of introductions
there's also a case for people in terms
of risk mitigation and verification
validation and certification the the
amount of code that's involved I I ran
into this relatively recently amount of
code involved in a current day automated
system like Google's or Mercedes system
is ten times that of a recent military
jet fighter so we're talking massive
amounts of code that need to be
exhaustively tested how do we do that
and especially how do we do that in
systems that may be non deterministic
they may not always respond exactly the
same way to the same stimuli that's the
thing we really don't know how to answer
when I save me I don't just mean I don't
you know independent computer scientists
I mean the department defense that this
is one of their big questions for
building automated system how do we test
them how do we make sure that they're
reliable and one of the ways to do that
that's been used historically and is
still being used is put someone in the
loop to sort of check those decisions
and interact with the system and there's
actually a whole engineering field
that's designing around this idea is
human factors engineering which takes
very seriously this idea of human
supervisory control or joint cognitive
systems development and these are sort
of close cousins ok I they're interested
I think in a lot of the same objects but
could a very different perspective so
from an AI perspective you could look at
the vehicle as a sort of object itself
you know how much intelligence is had
without what are its capabilities in a
human human supervisory control human
factors perspective you look at the
human and the vehicle as the system
trying to accomplish certain sorts of
tasks and that have certain
interrelationships of of control of
supervision of agency within that and
one of these ideas is let the human do
what he or she is best out whether
that's identifying whether a certain
like social behavior is threatening or
non threatening or crossing the street
or doing something else or whether
that's a sort of high-level management
focus you know where you want to go what
we want to do but there's another case
here which is the fundamental case which
is that full automation simply does not
exist automation is about human goals
that response to human needs and
therefore it comes from it involves an
important point here is that it doesn't
necessarily reduce labor but it changes
the form of that labor and it displaces
that later in space and in time so
instead of occurring within the vehicle
at the time of operation it might occur
before hand in an organization where
programmers are working to design the
code to deal with these sorts of
situations or it might occur at the same
time but at a different location in
space in a remote data center you know
somewhere across the world where the
system is being monitored but however
you cut it this process still involves
people it involves people in development
these cars require a lot of testing and
and programming to make work this was a
job posting for google it actually my
father sent to me about a month ago but
like you should see this self-driving
vehicle operator allocation decision
we're looking for vehicle safety
specialists to be a part of Google
self-driving car project responsible for
operating a vehicle for six to eight
hours per day collecting data so there's
a lot of this labor that goes into these
systems they also involve people in
management and this is I think a point I
can best make by a sort of historical
analogy with means of production that
you know factory work comes up to
replace artisan shops over certain
eighteenth and nineteenth centuries
there are a lot of changes involved in
that process including many sort of shop
floor workers turning into menial
machine tenders responsible for just
sitting there and pressing the bottom
and ensuring the operation machinery but
it doesn't just do that it also
generates new cultures of machinists and
mechanics who are responsible for
designing machines building machines
installing repairing them operator and
it also creates new management roles and
strengthens management culture so
there's some of that that control about
what's being done that gets moved from
the person on the floor to these new
management positions responsible for
sort of strategy so even in that factory
space people are still very much
involved
not only that it also involves people in
operations and I think a good place
historically to go for this is space
Verna condom saw astronauts as missile
riders that you would get into his
vehicle you would press a button it
would take you to space you with dear
science it would return each other so
didn't have to didn't have to interact
with the machine but that was on how
these systems were designed for a number
of reasons including that if you're
putting somebody in a machine that you
know can very easily kill them they
quite reasonably want to have some sort
of control over what's going on and so
when you get the Apollo system where you
have a digital computer but you also
have all sorts of manual backups and
switches then you also get situations
like today on the left you have a
combination of the robotic and human you
know actors working together to do
assembly and repair in space and this is
an image that sort of reminiscent of the
person in the data center that I showed
in the beginning but that's man space
what about unmanned systems which you
can say like those must be more
autonomous and the Mars rovers are
popularly seen methylated spirit and
opportunity are figured in a sort of
anthropomorphic way as making
discoveries but if you pull back the
curtain a little bit you see a big room
at JPL with a bunch of people in it
monitoring these systems and interacting
with them on a daily basis sometimes
actually living on Mars time rather than
Earth time and you're acting at least
once per day sending commands receiving
replies these vehicles can actually do
automated pathfinding so if they know
their location and you from the
destination they can figure out how to
get there but that capability is rarely
ever used instead you have you know the
engineers responsible sit down and plot
out the trajectory give those
instructions and actually when the
rover's are out of contact with the
earth they could operate autonomously
but they that they are not allowed to
instead of their tolls just sit in place
and do what they can in a particular
location but it's teams of too risky to
allow them to water around by their own
without that constant human supervision
so why does this matter why does this
hybridity and historical examples of it
matter well they matter because we can
expect automation to have major social
compact social impacts in terms of
produce not only how much does the road
get used but who gets to use it are
there important class dynamics to who
gets more mobility it gets less mobility
it matters in terms of congestion one of
the big questions of these sorts of
systems is are you making driving easier
more seamless therefore more people will
take more trips and actually the traffic
situation get worse or can you offset
that with the increased efficiencies of
the system do you have enough interest
efficiency of your gaining by increasing
fees or automated control to make up for
more people using the system you have
questions of pervasive monitoring are we
setting ourselves up for your big load
of surveillance by putting video cameras
on all of our vehicles how is that data
management handled and we also have
these ethical dilemmas that we ran into
before with Dudley not talking about
these vehicles are you know very much to
sort of classical trolling problem
waiting to half of your life and you
know how do we deal with that on how do
you think about that and all of these
questions depend on the engineering
approach that you take including where
the human is involved how they are
involved what their role is why then do
we automated systems well we automated
systems to reduce the failure rate of
people because there are certain things
that we're not particularly good at but
we don't we don't only do that we also
automate systems to increase human
agency to increase the agency of a group
of people on earth in
the JPL lab to do things on Mars and we
also automate to increase management
control over production for good or ill
not sort of making that argument here
but it's so this is not to say that
automation makes the human less
important in fact here you have the
National Research Council talking about
automation Houston civil aviation saying
humans role becomes more rather than
less important than moving towards the
autonomous end of the spectrum because
it is so important to assure that the
systems are properly designed tested
deployed and monitor and then you have
the park cast working group which is a
prominent their airline safety working
root in the US which says that an
exclusive focus on pilot barriers will
not take into account the positive
actions and decisions that pilots do on
a frequent basis so the idea here is
that just add automation isn't the
answer alone taking what we think of as
a car today or we have their car today
and having automated systems to it
doesn't ballon achieve any sort of
social good instead you have to start
from the desired impact what do you want
to do with the system do you want to
increase safety by sort of factor of 100
do you want to decrease the
environmental impact of technology do
you want to provide mobility for poor
the elderly the disabled these are all
positive goals they're all good things
that we could get behind but they're
also not all equally served by the same
engineering approaches and some of these
goals actually may turn out to conflict
with each other providing more mobility
for more people may actually be
detrimental to the environment that may
be an issue where you know those two
goals are conflict
so to conclude all tasks are hybrid
tasks what I'm saying is that no system
is fully automated and we shouldn't just
sort of take for granted this idea that
systems move from all human involvement
to no human involvement second that that
human involvement is both a weakness and
strength we are both sources of failure
and also sources of great success I'm
going to focus on the people to focus on
people how people are involved in
automated systems both now and in the
past changes the questions that we ask
rather than asking how do we get rid of
people how do we make things more
automated instead I think when we sort
of see that fundamentally all these
systems involve people we can start
asking well how should they be involved
what are the appropriate roles for
people to achieve particular goals and
to sort of start from both gold and move
come towards the engineering system and
finally I want to close with a sort of
note of caution here which is that
automation responds to human goals but
it also serves some goals and serves
some people to over others and to sort
of go back to that factory model that I
brought up earlier you know if one of
the effects of automation in the factory
was to create two very disparate classes
of labor the sort of creative managers
who are in charge of large-scale
strategy and then the menial machine
tenders who are responsible for just
sitting there and pressing the button
that doesn't mean that we shouldn't
automate things but we should be very
careful as designers as legislators and
as citizens about how about automation
is being done and what role he end up in
because we may have to be very careful
to ensure that we end up not as the sort
of menial machine tenders for you know
high the sort of you know capital
investments of multinational software
companies that design these things and
keep all that sort of
management role salt thank you any
takers yes so you've brought up about
public perception of only eight vehicles
as partly revolves I then people in the
vehicle all the people responsible
operated in Qatar so what about of
discussion about people about you know
the rest of the infrastructure that
could change yeah so comedy that's right
now everything that is he is actually
all the only the only tactical decision
is when the turbine hit yeah but we
teach kids how to stay on three trends
that's it let's watch a good change yeah
I think that's a good point it is
something I deal with a little bit in
the thesis itself looking at models from
the sort of you know reshaping of the
street around the automobile in the
first place in around the streetcar and
different boats behavior that come out
of that that the street didn't used to
be a place just for vehicles one of the
one of the main concerns that I have run
into about people and these are concerns
that we see reflected in news articles
and sort of things that reach a certain
popular audience is whether we're going
to make city force that there's a lot of
talk from the sort of urban planning
slide about that mr. automobile has
ruined cities especially in this country
especially in Asia perhaps and you know
we need to move away from that and one
way to do that productively maybe
through vehicle automation but not
necessarily and so that's actually
that's actually an interesting space
where you do see nuance about well this
you know this could decrease traffic but
it could also make it
much more sort of difficult to get
around as a pedestrian one thing I'll
mention just on that point was from a
presentation that i went to actually at
the Media Lab last year where you have
someone talking about replacing all
traffic lights with a sort of slot based
system so all of your automated vehicles
could drive up and as they get close to
the intersection they could request a
slot and then go through in a sort of
complex computer choreographed way
rather than having to wait for traffic
to be done or direction and there was
actually a very pointed question that
was asked about what what about
bicyclist is what about pedestrians and
there wasn't a very good answer to that
and my thought had been you know what
does that do for you know maybe a
homeless person who doesn't have a
smartphone how do they then get across
that Street if everything is just based
on plum and that's a question you do
sometimes see those things come up into
popular press I actually see those
concerns less in these sort of
engineering spaces that I've looked into
those those documents that's much more
focused on like the technological
approach and that approach is often
though not always very focused on the
individual vehicle because i think you
know companies like Google and sort of
decided that they can't depend on any
broader sort of governmental push to
change the infrastructure because people
have been talking about automated
vehicle systems since 50s at least in a
sort of real way but they would have
required other infrastructural changes
and that was part of the reason I think
those didn't ever get off the ground so
there there's so sort of there's some
talk about the sort of broader
infrastructure and I tried to dress
a little bit but I mean I think that's
an important
shopping carts wanna everything seemed
very good then you get into the drones
ish human I heard that but wait you
mentioned the NHTSA's for an overt acts
on deck to make initial did about 10
good in that yeah yeah so um well I mean
it's good that there's a document out
there that tries to address this because
it is a space that really does I think
needs some guidance so that companies
can have some idea of a little be
expected of them from the sort of
governmental perspective and presumably
so that legislators can get some insight
into what's actually going on whether
what are the technologies I think
there's two major problems with that
taxonomy one of them I sort of talked
about already which is that the levels
are very artificial that we in level 0
you have you know automatic
transmissions are not automation that's
in the no automation category and also
information automation which is a
well-recognized category of human
factors research those encounters
automation so if it's only an automated
system that's giving you as the driver
you know information about roadway
conditions that doesn't count in that
system that's level 0 and that you know
doesn't seem to really make sense to me
doesn't sort of your productive way to
talk about that when I set up has 0 1 2
3 4 the audience they sort of want to
get before and I think it could be a
sort of different document if it didn't
take that hierarchical structure the
other problem with it is that within
each of those levels there it is there
sort of very discreet so level one is
that one axis of the vehicles automated
either accelerator and brake important
turning level two is that both axes are
automated level three is that both axes
are automated and you can not pay
attention to it for a bit like if you're
on the highway in level 4 would be both
axes are automated and you can not pay
attention to it all of the time but even
in vehicles today we're undergoing sort
of complicated transactions on a
minute-by-minute basis with automation
you know if sort of you know if I let go
of the wheel in my vehicle that I'm sort
of trusting to a very mechanical
automated system that just keeps me
going straight like this reason our
vehicles are stable that hasn't really
changed a property of the vehicle but
there's been a sort of transfer of
agency there and if you are going up a
hill and your vehicle slowing down a bit
you may push a little bit harder on the
accelerator because even though you have
an automatic transmission you sort of
want some input into that system but
those complex dynamics of what you're
actually doing is a driver on if I made
a basis in terms of how you're working
with the system they just can't have all
be dealt with with that the way that
that taxonomy set up because it's it's a
sort of very hard official description
of how these systems work and I actually
think the society a lot of mode of
engineers does a better job with theirs
because released I think six months
before after I don't remember which were
looking on but that one's better at sort
of dealing some of these nuances though
it still has its own problems
Jesse you mentioned that it's not a good
model man
hit apartment on Climate going that way
but you just see
port on the system that certain areas
roads only or or something's just might
pose too much repellent ever will be
executive courses okay I mean I think I
think sir segregated operations areas
are a totally possible thing I mean
that's actually happening right now a
lot of the driverless cars are in my
report or driverless cars are in no
other area the world they're sort of low
speed golf carts and it's a very
particular you know physical regime in
which they where they can go slow
they're dealing with pedestrians but in
in collision people get injured and
there's also a case to be made for
things like you know other sort of rapid
transit systems that are sort of like
automobiles and operating on separate in
separate areas I think again I guess I
would just say that that the question of
are there are there places that are too
complicated to ever fully automate is a
question that sort of makes more sense
when what you're thinking about is that
we want to fully automate things and
it's a question that makes less sense
when you start asking you know are there
particular rules that we always want
human beings involved in and then you
know what is full automation mean in
that goes like do we always be a human
being somehow watching the system to be
sort of ethically responsible for you no
accidents or other other issues that
happen is that something that we're just
like I mean a bit too squeamish to to
let that be a decision that some
humanism
and then I mean is that is that a fully
automated system anymore if if it's like
here's an area where you can build that
but we decide you need that person there
to be looking at it and I'd say it's
it's not a fully automated system and
sister that's not a great term precisely
for the reasons that somehow line